alors quoi de
[Musique]
beau
moi j'ai plus rien à faire parce que je
suis à retraite ben voilà donc ce
weekend tu fais quoi toi alors ce
weekend je vais au champignons OK ou
parce que j'ai rien à
faire av une vie trpidante à la
retraite je fais que des trucs de loisir
qui servent à
rien je à la pêche au champignons ouais
je fais du VTT
ouais vous faites plein de trucs en
quand même vachement vachement de truc
qui rien
[Musique]
voilà
une touche ça dire quoi ça tu Tas touch
un truc oui il y un poisson qui ok qui a
tapé dans mon leur plutôt bon
signe tu l' laissé encore trop ou trop
c'est
l'habitude l'habitude mais tuas pas
l'habitude en mer on fait comme ça ah
bon vach AC
ventess de faire passer pour un mec qui
conna mieux
qu' poisson non ah non oui non oui vas-y
vasy il est
parti
regarde quoi c'est quoi c'est quoi
arrête je prends le micro tu veux de
l'aide tu veux de l'aide est-ce qu'on
peut avoir l'puis oui tout de suite son
assistant maintenant
alors attention pas bless par je me
blesse
pas
vasyève et là tu la TI tu la tires vers
toi voil voil
voil
voilas raté ta
journéeose moi je veux te voir avec le
poisson je veux la
photoi tiensle bien parce qu'il va il va
sauter glisse en plus non moi j'ai
peur tu le prends comme ça et tu le
tiens fermement à la tête là
[Musique]
d'accord
[Rires]
c'était sûr cétait
sûr on fait quoi alors du coup photo
c'est pas
[Musique]
mal
et on prépare Noël avec
la faille tomber prépare là